do
[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
i'm pierce morgan on sensor coming up on
tonight's program stanley johnson will
be here to talk trophy hunting for big
beasts and endangered species i'll also
ask him about animals
money over morals has sports sold out to
saudi arabia football legend harry
redknapp will be here live
and she lost a cool case to johnny depp
but amber heard us not stop playing the
victim
do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony
[Music]
[Music]
well good evening bad news i'm afraid to
start amber heard is still yapping uh
she's broken her silence which didn't
last very long in a new sit-down
interview after her defamation trial
lost to ex-husband johnny depp insisting
that he's the liar and repeating claims
he assaulted her during their marriage
because we've heard all this before
haven't we and the more that she whines
and plays the victim rather like that
other american actress meghan markle the
less credible she becomes
this is the most humiliating and
horrible thing i've ever been through in
the vast majority of this trial was
played out on social media the jury saw
it
how could they not it would have been
impossible
to avoid this he says you start physical
fights and you say i did start a
physical fight i can't promise you i
won't get physical again
i mean this is in black and white i
understand context
but you're testifying and you're just
telling me today i never started a
physical fight and here you are on tape
saying you did as i testified on the
stand about this is that when your life
is at risk
not only will you take the blame for
things that you shouldn't take the blame
for but when you're in an abusive
dynamic psychologically
emotionally and physically you don't
have the resources that say you or i do
with the luxury of saying hey this is
black and white but then there are other
times there's another tape where you're
taunting him and saying oh tell the
world johnny depp i a man the victim of
domestic violence 20 second clips or the
transcripts of them
are not representative of even the two
hours or the three hours that those
clips are excerpt from he says doesn't
never
hit you
he never is that a lie yes it is in the
closing arguments the depth lawyers
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime what do you say to that says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers when i asked
his lawyers why do you think you won and
the answer i got was
because she never took responsibility
for anything
she did in the marriage
i
did do and say horrible
regrettable things throughout my
relationship do you think that maybe he
just had better lawyers i will say his
his lawyers did certainly a better job
of distracting the jury from the real
issues do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony
i'm joined now by civil rights attorney
lisa bloomberg i'd love to talk to you
again um
when i watched this this morning on the
today show i've got to be honest with
you my mind went back to meghan markle's
oprah winfrey to uh winathon
because the longer amber heard talks
frankly
the more she whines the more she plays
the victim the more she tries to blame
everybody but herself as with meghan
markle the the less i believe her i just
find her a really incredible or
uncredible witness
or both actually
well you certainly have a right to your
opinion peers and i have a right to mine
i have a lot of sympathy for amber heard
i agree with the couple's marriage
counselor that they were both abusive to
each other and there's no question that
she was vilified on social media as she
says she had to go into court pass
blocks and blocks of johnny depp super
fans holding up signs that she deserved
to die i mean this was a horrific
experience for her she stands by her
testimony my concern for her is is she
going to get hit with a new defamation
case because now she's out there calling
him a liar right and also my question
would be if johnny depp had lost that
case would he have been allowed on the
today show to call his victim a liar to
stand by everything that he'd said i
don't think he would have been given the
platform so to me there's a double
standard there you've been involved in
many of these these cases i know but i
think there's a real double standard
there
i think that today's show would have
been thrilled to have him on if he lost
to tell his side or any of these
high-profile guys uh who are accused i
don't think that's a problem i don't
think he has a problem having a platform
he's got a massive platform he's an
a-list celebrity he's wealthy beyond all
imagining i don't think that would have
been no i don't think well i don't think
this was a good idea for amber though no
i thought it was a total train wreck for
her but my point being i don't think
that today's show would have given
johnny depp the chance to continue
playing the victim if he'd been found
guilty of domestic violence and my issue
watching amber home was right a jury
didn't believe her you know 95 of the of
the virgin went johnny depp's way they
thought she was the liar and in fact the
only hard evidence that came out during
the entire case
about domestic actual violence physical
violence was by her not by johnny depp
yes but keep in mind she used the term
domestic abuse which includes emotional
abuse sexual abuse psychological abuse
she never said in that op-ed that was
the center of the whole case that he
physically abused her and i also think
samantha guthrie at the today show did a
pretty good job she's an attorney uh i
know samantha a little bit she's tough
and i think she did a pretty good job of
saying look just as you just said piers
look amber heard uh the jury didn't
believe you the jury felt that you were
a liar i mean she really you know
did a pretty tough interview there you
know the problem i have lisa with with
the whole thing with amber heard and
i've got no great truck for johnny depp
by the way i think he came out of it
pretty awfully too
but i think his behavior since has been
a lot more respectful to the process he
certainly hasn't you know tried to
hammer things home with with amber heard
in the press by you know continuing to
rant about her but
my whole problem with it if you go back
to that first piece that she wrote we
now live in a in a culture in a society
where there is a premium to people
to play the victim to write these kind
of heart-rending op-eds positioning
themselves as these terrible victims
what became clear through this case was
that at very best this was a mutually
toxic
abusive situation she certainly wasn't
the victim
and yet there she was taking space in a
major national newspaper
to write this searing op-ed as a kind of
representative for the victims of
domestic violence and i think that that
goes to in my mind
this culture we now have where people
can build a career out of victimhood and
many of them do it and i think it
diminishes
real victims people who are really
suffering
really being abused really the victims
of domestic violence and i'm cynical
about it and i'm seeing it more and more
and like what is happening when
when there's that mindset
well i i don't necessarily agree with
you piers that people make careers out
of victimhood because i represent dozens
and dozens of victims of sexual abuse
and race discrimination right now in my
law firm and i can tell you
none of my clients want to be in this
position they wish it never happened
they wish they could just go on with
their lives most of them never do any
media they just want justice they just
want some fairness and accountability
and with regard to amber hurd and johnny
depp they can both be victims and i
think there are many marriages where the
both parties abuse each other and it's
horrific and they can both be hurting
and in the article she talked about the
massive backlash that she had gotten in
hollywood for saying that she was a
victim and clearly what we've seen a
massive social media hate for amber
heard and and what she's had to
experience in the last a couple of
months of this trial uh not it's not
something but again you know i i agree
yeah look i don't i don't like the
social media pile on with her it can get
very nasty very ugly but her insinuation
the jury must have been reading all this
and that's why they found against her i
think is extremely in my view
disrespectful to the process to the
court case to the jury it's like i'm
pretty sure they're not allowed to read
any social media so maybe one or two did
we don't know we're not supposed to
right so little supposedly you're not
supposed to but you and i know
piers when was the last time you were
off of twitter for six weeks
uh probably before twitter
six minutes most of us are pretty
addicted
most of us are pretty addicted to social
media whether it's instagram or twitter
or whatever it is and to say that they
were all entirely off for six weeks that
none of their friends and family members
talk to them about it i mean do we
really believe that nobody could be it
could be these i could work with juries
but also they say one thing and they do
another thing i know but ultimately to
me
it comes back to this thing where all
women must be believed as a starting
point for these kind of cases i think
all women should be listened to and
evidence should be studied
but i think the clear
overwhelming sort of fallout from meghan
markle oprah winfrey amber heard in this
court case is that actually no not all
women should be automatically believed
because sometimes they're telling
porcupies
well listen no sane person says that all
women must be believed i mean that's
absurd i think you're right a lot of
people do say that any accuser i
represent men
i don't know about a lot of people
saying that peers maybe there's always
fringe people on both sides of things
but i think we want to take these
allegations seriously i think what the
metoo movement has taught us that a lot
more people are sexually abused and
sexually harassed than we ever knew in
the past and we're all taking this a lot
more seriously and we should and a lot
of prominent people mostly men have been
taken down by the metoo movement and
they should have and so overall it's a
positive thing but there's always going
to be outliers people who make up
stories and we have to have due process
i agree with you i listen i agree with
everything you just said i think i think
that most of the me too movement and
time's up movements have been
long overdue and very necessary a lot of
bad people have been held a proper
account i just think when i watch
someone like amber heard i see an
actress
and i see somebody who lost but who
doesn't want to admit she lost she's a
kind of donald trump
well johnny depp is a more successful
actor
sorry
johnny depp yeah but johnny johnny
he's a far more successful actor why
isn't he accused of acting well he's on
the stand i just know if johnny depart
lost there's no way he'd have been
allowed to carry on calling his victim a
liar on prime time american television
they wouldn't have allowed it
well you know i'll defer to you you know
more about television than i do i'm just
a simple civil rights lawyer
representing victims i'm not actually
sure about that you see you're a very
accomplished television performer these
days uh great to talk to you thank you
very much
always good to see you thank you peers
well i says the next uh stanley johnson
his son
uh was obviously too scared to be
interviewed by me runs into fridges to
avoid me but his father is made of
tougher stuff
there is the prime minister's dad will
be here live and unleashed to talk about
endangered species big beasts facing
possible extinction
and a sport sold out to saudi arabia
where the great harry redknapp will be
here to talk about sports washing what
is it does it matter and the first
flight transporting asylum seekers
communicated rwanda leaves in just over
an hour but we're now down to just six
people on board at vast expense will
this controversial migrant policy take
off bolton and richard thais
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well an endangered species is a beast
considered highly likely to become
extinct in the near future fending
increasingly for themselves they're put
at risk by the loss of territory their
plight is made worse by ruthless
poachers who often want to bring them
down as a trophy to their own prowess
sadly these big beasts sometimes too
deluded to realize that it's already
over it's into the poor marksmanship of
the hapless hunters that spares them
their futures
stanley johnson is here you're not
talking
aren't you
happier stanley i'm obviously talking uh
trophy hunting and endangered speeches
no let's start first of all i sense the
trap it's not a trap uh let's just be
completely upfront about this talking of
endangered species uh who may be facing
yeah possible end your son boris
i have to ask you about it because he
won't come on the show i've been i've
been interviewed in seven years
now let's talk if i'm writing about
endangered species
but let me talk about boris first all
right then we'll come to the trophy and
your book
i'm just curious you're his dad right
he's been through one hell of a
period in his life
he becomes prime minister he gets brexit
done he's then hit by a global pandemic
he's hit by a war in ukraine uh he's hit
by all sorts of stuff surging inflation
now in the middle of it he gets covered
and nearly dies his mother dies
you put all this together that's a hell
of a two and a half years for any human
being
as his father
when you've watched him
go through all this what have you been
thinking i've been thinking i am very
proud of this boy of this man
of this pm i mean that's what i say to
myself i mean he caught you know the big
calls right and that's right like i'm
saying he's got a lot of things right
you know okay i'm an environmentalist i
think the way he pushed on climate
change the way he pushed on biodiversity
the way he pushed if we get to it so
this is about endangered species yeah
it's fine and honestly you know if you
ask me my my absolute opinion on this
i'd say i'd say i i listened to what you
what imran khan said to you the other
day you know people in in karachi
bewildered at the attention which this
this party gate beargate but you know
why it's had it's rattled people the
party is not really about parties right
you and i have been to a lot of parties
together right it's all about it's not
about the parties it's about the at the
time when he and his government were
locking people in their homes and they
couldn't go and see dying relatives who
were literally dying in hospital from
coving that was the rule the law when
the queen was at her own husband's
funeral sitting on her own because she
wanted to abide by the letter of the law
there is boris the prime minister being
fined by the police for breaking his own
law and 84 of his staff
signed for an illegal party so that's
the scandal no well i don't actually see
it in that in that way because i see it
something that happened on the 19th of
on the 19th of june 2020 which was just
a few weeks after he came out of out of
hospital having been really seriously
ill he steps by for for 20 minutes
it's his birthday he comes a birthday
party he broke his own laws down yeah
come on come on pierce we're not done
take my word for it take the police's
word for it okay
i think that
that
is time is time to move on from that you
know
it was a situation where yes
he has a drink
he would put this had a glass in his
hand
and that was it that was the end of it
it's all about the drink is it it's
about having a party which breaks his
own
hair when he was telling other people
every day from the podium you can't do
this it's the doing one thing and
preaching another no you know that look
i know you're in charge of this
interview and no reason why you
shouldn't because you know you're the
you're the big cheese but i didn't come
here you know that's all i'm concerned
it's high time we moved on to things
which really matter which are the things
he is doing now do you see it's the
things he's doing
and you mentioned them you know curvy
let's hope that's out of the way
inflation he's got to deal with it
ukraine ukraine well who is taking the
lead on ukraine i think he's been good
on ukraine yeah i think i think boris
has been i think he's been a leader on
ukraine and on the big calls on kovid i
think he got some right and some
horribly wrong of the first half of it
he was a complete disaster the second
half i thought with the vaccine program
rolled out and not locking down actually
at the end of the last year i think
there were two important calls he got
right britain feels a much freer country
right now than if you go abroad so i
think he's got some of the goals right
but the idea he's got all the big calls
right well i think it's a bit ridiculous
right i don't think i said that i think
he i think he's got you know
many of the big calls right and that's
that i think is crucial and you know as
long as i'm concerned i am because you
asked me the question i am particularly
pleased to see this son of mine
being prime minister whether other sons
would be brightness another matter but i
am very very pleased about this and long
may he love danny when you see him being
attacked repeatedly for being dishonest
for being amoral all those things what
do you feel about it you know him better
than most people yeah this is what i
feel i feel this is a lot of garbage i
mean total garbage i see this as the
worst kind of journalism i'm not going
to name the journalists i hope i don't
have to meet them but honestly i think
it's and i think it's tinged with look
it's a hunting scene isn't it we're
going to get on to hunting we are going
to go
it's a hunting scene there we are they
think the beast is wounded let's scale
up after him let's fire a shoot few more
shots it is it is absurd we have to move
is he irreparably wounded by the fact
that 42
of conservative mps don't have
confidence in him no i don't think in
some country if you look at the figures
more conservative mps voted in a
confidence vote for boris johnson than
have ever voted for it for a
conservative prime minister in any
confidence vote look at the figures no
it may be that's because there were more
conservative mps to vote that's why okay
that's why but why were there more
conservative mps it was because
that doesn't work leave the percentage
out of it leave the sheer numbers the
percentage is all that matters sheer
numbers got that result and you cannot
deny that the the 368 tory mps who were
elected in
2019 were elected you know
you're a star political animal you know
that actually
the stats are now heavily against him
hardly any conservative prime minister
has ever survived much longer than six
months from a no-confidence vote even if
they they all win them but the margin of
the win is what brings them down let me
tell you something i am completely
confident that
at this time two years from now you and
i will be having this conversation
possibly and you will be saying well
you're still the father of prime
minister vincent you know what you that
might be true i'm not saying necessarily
that should be what happens but i think
you might be right he has got the
escapology skills of harry houdini
hasn't he
eugenie as i recall eventually died
because someone he did
struck him in the tummy rather i'm not
mentioning jeremy hump but you know
you've got to be careful who's around
him at the moment um
look
we need to concentrate on the main
things as far as i'm concerned why i'm
here tonight is there's a crucial moment
when this government i'm not criticizing
my prime minister i'm not doing that but
nonetheless just to show i am not as it
were starry-eyed i am deeply worried
that the proposal the government
um has
promised to make regarding
banning trophy hunting imports has not
yet seen the light of day well let's be
really clear about this because i agree
with you about trophy hunting i think
it's a disgusting thing and it shouldn't
be allowed to happen boris said he was
going to get rid of it and he hasn't so
he's gone back on his word
well it's to you no he stands this is in
the word is the word as it appeared in
the conservative party manifesto and if
you ask the government about it the
government says firmly we are still if
you talk to him privately about it i
don't go into what i say privately to my
son and i wouldn't expect him to say
what he says to me you know on there but
nonetheless on this sort of thing i
would prefer to speak out loud to you
peers in the privacy of this studio yes
if you see what i mean the government
has to move on this because i don't want
to say for those who haven't followed
this whole saga what is it exactly you
and a lot of signatories to a letter
want to get
what done okay
trophy hunting is still
massively practiced all around the world
and by the way british sportsmen are
massively involved in trophy hunting and
we
have a time when endangered species
aren't truly endangered and we've got
the animals we've got the the
lions the rhinos and the wrong men i
agree
they're all all there and yet people are
still getting prizes from the safari
club international you know for killing
hundred different species of animals
people are paying fifty thousand dollars
to flying from america from absolutely
minnesota we saw the cecil reliance
absolutely so i want the government to
really deliver on its promise to bring
in this law banning the import of of
trophies and also i want the government
to push hard now on this other thing
which is again in the manifesto which is
to do with animals abroad and the fact
that british tourists
are going off in huge numbers postscoped
to places like thailand and india and
other places where animals are abused
for spectacles and entertainment
particularly if you've reached a point
of agreement although i would point out
on trophy i'm saying yeah look at this
it's also a prime example of your of
your son saying one thing and not doing
it
no he is
got every chance to do it that is the
point he's watching this program what's
your message for him about trophy sorry
watch his watches
every day he ever comes on it well i
can't get out of the fridge
i can't speak to that but i am convinced
that environment remains a top priority
of this government climate change
maintenance top priority biodiversity
marines and animal species okay
is there you've got a great new book out
from an antique land you've written how
many books are uh this is my 25th
unbelievable where did you get the
energy you johnson's no i don't have any
injuries
relentless isn't that it's a very nice
thing to say that is a thriller that is
a thriller and it's all to do with what
happened in cambodia in 1975. i look
forward to reading it i like all your
books the i wanted to show you a bit of
footage this is of a [ __ ] uh a cockrell
in turkey this is the moment stanley
where i think you and i probably boris
as well have a moment don't we
occasionally when you just want to do
this watch this
[Applause]
you sure that's not the call
[Laughter]
it's not the fakeness johnson mating i
think it could be the call of the word
scene if it comes from turkey
watch the end though stan you see what
happens at the end here
it's going it's going now the last time
the last time i saw a magnificent beast
like that doing something similar was
when you came on good morning britain
and we got you to do a handstand
remember this come on i don't remember
it's really sensible yep
say it then i'm happy to say it now
stanley it's great to see you as always
effervescent presence and you are a
cheater i've got to tell you appears you
know you lured me in here it was a bit
like chess on the line
i'm a trophy hunter i learned in the
nothing wrong with defending your son by
the way and we got to talk about trophy
hunting and your book and i showed you
doing a handstand the world's looking
for stanley are thank you peers
good to see you
see you all folks
tell boris to come in soon we'd have fun
cheers dally good to see
i you he's going to get boris out of the
fridge to get him on the show
well on censor next the british
government flies migrants to rwanda
impactful or immoral this is next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
well from big beasts uh to two more big
beasts uh it's the piers pack talk tv
contributor adam bolton talk to the
presenter and leader of reform uk
richard thais welcome heavyweights
uh did stanley pass you on the way out
i said you're a cheats yeah
i don't think so i'm not taking that
from them either um but it's a good
interview i like i like stanley um let's
talk about rwanda richard because i i do
think this is a genuinely complicated
issue we've got a live shot here of uh
boston down and wheelchairs is the plane
that's due to leave in about a half an
hour's time we're down to apparently six
people are now on this flight which
makes it incredibly expensive obviously
does it even make it worth it if he's
trying to prove this point does this
prove anything i think what it proves is
the principle the principle is whether
or not the government the elected
government of the day can carry out one
of the key policies that it was elected
on which was to get brexit done which
included taking back control of our
borders so i think it's really really
important that the plane goes and we've
been through not one not two three court
process in the uk and yet the european
court of human rights seems to have
decided it wants to interfere even if
there's nobody on that plane it should
still go with the blessing of the
domestic corps so here's my issue with
it i think what's going on on the sea
is
unacceptable it cannot just go on like
this exactly you can have more and more
boats and more and more people drowning
it's just not acceptable for us to look
at that and think we do nothing
but i can't find it in my heart to think
this is british
to then take people many of whom are
genuine asylum seekers albeit trying to
enter the country illegally but many of
them have come from genuine war zones
that we simply say to them right we know
you've come from syria we know you've
come from afghanistan we know you come
from iraq which we bombed by the way but
what we're going to do we're going to
put you on the first plane to rwanda
look there are no good options we all
want to be somewhere else which is
comfortable about that
all of these are bad options i think i
think the government has tried it's
tried to work with france everything
else has failed and essentially this is
saying it's another last-ditch attempt i
also think he appears that rowan is
actually getting a very bad press by
quite a lot of people here who may not
know what they're thinking about for
example the united nations own report
recently said and i'll just read it out
rwanda's made notable sprite strides
toward improving people's lives there's
a hundred and thirty thousand refugees
there rwanda has been impressive with
progress rowan has done an excellent job
integrating refugees it's built over
five hundred classrooms for twenty
thousand as i mentioned as i mentioned
last night
as an arsenal fan we have on our shirts
the players visit rwanda i think it's
getting a very bad press okay
first of all this is not about rwanda
people say nice things about rwanda i've
never been there
because this is about people who came
through europe uh to britain and who
wanted to stay in britain so you know we
ended deportation for criminals i think
in the 19th century so
i think the whole idea of
of of of deporting people is you know to
quote prince charles appalling or
shaming or ugly as the tory mp uh jesse
norman says but the real test is is it
going to work right right and and that's
where you've fallen for this i mean
you're not a tory i know you've got your
own party but you know the fact is this
is a cruel gesture politics
because they've got six people on the
plane yeah we know contrary to taking
back control of our borders actually
immigration is going up in this country
if that's what people are really
concerned about
they're more people
came in come in every day than they're
even thinking of deporting
to rwanda we know they've only prepared
76 places in rwanda with the money
that's been given so far so this is not
going to become and shouldn't become
mass deposit we also know this richard
let me put this to you because it's just
an interesting thing that i read about
today we found some information about it
so between 2014 and 2017 israel operated
a similar scheme sending people to
rwanda and uganda under a voluntary
scheme migrants were given a choice to
return to their own country or accept a
payment of 2 700 pounds and a plane
ticket to east africa or go to jail if
they stayed in israel
now apparently a lot of people took the
option of going to east africa but then
left
and they actually migrated to other
parts of europe
it didn't solve the problem that was
then this is now i refer to what i just
read out earlier in terms of the unzone
report amnesty international is more
critical of spain's performance with
migrants and refugees and indeed the uk
than it is of rwanda ultimately we've
got i think we're all agreed we've got
to have a deterrent to stop people
coming across the channel this may or
may not work my hunch is that it
probably won't because the odds for the
reasons you've just mentioned of you
actually um going from the uk to rwanda
are remarkably low you know my
preference actually is to keep working
with the french and to have a joint
arrangement where anybody who comes
across the channel is is picked up
safely taken back to france you have a
joint processing center and they are
promptly rapidly processed okay i mean
look for the friendship resistance but
the friendships are showing knowing
that's the problem is we can't so you
have to do a problem but you have to try
new things right to activate the terror
yeah what about ukraine when you the war
in ukraine happened we suddenly have a
massive influx of ukrainians now they're
not entering illegally
vast majority they're coming here
legally but we are working very hard to
process very quick asylum for these
people nothing nothing compared to other
european countries right but we're still
doing it what i mean is that our system
seems to work fine with ukraine well
this is why why can't we get a better
sense of
people
this is what you hear from people like
nadim zahawi uh that there are ways to
come in actually if you're in libya if
you're in um iran if you're in iraq
there aren't easy ways for you to you
know for you to apply and and and come
in so i'm not i'm not saying you should
try and be uh illegal but they're there
they are actually
not telling the public the truth when
they say it's easy for people um
if we accept that the random thing
probably isn't gonna work i know you
will but either way if it's not doing
something like that something dramatic
we try and make a big deterrent
statement what should we do about
stopping so many people risking their
lives to come over on these dinghies
well i agree with richard i think we
should be
working with other european countries
but of course thanks to brexit uh we're
not working now thank you thank you
thank you thank you emmanuel we're not
inventing that particular thing that i
just said yes
because it could happen because
because we've chosen to go
to
a menu where we think we can pick and
choose rather than actually operate in
an alliance and and you know people were
told okay that's going to put up the
drawbridge and actually through
government incompetence it hasn't put up
the drawbridge people are still coming
in and once they recognize and see that
i think the government's going to be in
big problems because their supporters
wanted that and that is why they are
doing this policy this policy is a pr
stunt to persuade people that they're
dealing
with smacks off to me as we know this
government is very good at talking the
talk all sorts of headlines short term
headline grabbing spin and then no
delivery and the reality is you've just
touched on it the home office is not fit
for purpose we saw in the early weeks of
the ukraine refugee crisis we were miles
behind we know that we're way too slow
with processing these claims but i just
want to put one point here which is
actually there's a lot of suggestions
we're not taking our sort of allocation
of asylum seekers and refugees that's
actually not true in the last three
years we're in the top four nations for
taking refugees from elsewhere in the
world and we've been taking them from
afghanistan we've been taking them from
ukraine we've been taking refugees
ukraine is a war zone obviously we've
we've been
widely very generous whenever i watch
people like nigel farage constantly
banging on about economic migrants and
saying these are young men in a very
disparaging way why do we demonize
economic migrants who might be of use to
our economy well i think the reality is
you know we always want a smart lawful
immigration system that works for our
economic needs at a particular time but
the key word is lawful as opposed to
illegal you can't just open all borders
and say everyone's welcome that's not
gonna work we know we've got huge
infrastructure problems housing problems
gp problems hospital problems so we've
got to plan for this on a sensible
grown-up basis and i think historically
we've actually been quite good at it
i agree with what you just said but i
don't agree that it is the british way
to just ship people off who may have
come from genuinely horrific places but
and horrific conditions which partly we
may have helped create iraq and so on we
just put them on a plane to someone like
rwanda well particularly if you're
paying half a million pounds per seat
right whatever it's costing to to get
them the number that numbers are
relevant if we're not
notices it is if we have 50 000 people
across the channel this year 40 grand
each in the first year that's two
billion
in one year on top of the current five
billion plus
that um
other things but i've actually really
enjoyed this debate i just want to end
by asking both of you you first richard
in a year's time will we still be
sending people to romander as this thing
dead in the water
well some unfortunate phrase you know
what i mean
i think that's unlikely and in a year's
time i suspect sadly there will still be
lots of refugees people illegal migrants
making that very dangerous uh voyage
trip across the channel adam we don't
want to have people dead in the water
but i don't want to have them flown off
to rwanda so there's got to be another
way
has this government got it in it do you
think to come up with another way in a
word no i mean the the precedent of
schemes like this is the israeli scheme
you mentioned is the australian scheme
you mentioned and both of them basically
have gone into stalemate now and they're
not sending vast amounts of people out
although there are some people still uh
but actually the australian school did
work it did stop well it did reduce the
number of people coming on the mountain
but they also had a lot of mistreatment
of people in these centers they put them
in and of course we don't want that
that's not the british way but the
british way is to actually find a
problem try and find a solution and
we've got to keep and the problem is no
one else has got an alternative
australia as they always point out has
a much greater flow of immigrants coming
into the country anyway i do agree
though when i listen to labour i don't
hear an answer right i hear a lot of
whining about what the tories are trying
to do i don't hear a credible answer
from them either it's a very complex
issue thank you richard thank you adam
good to see you both and since the nexus
golf stars spurned the pga for saudi
back rival is sports washing as they
call it selling out well football legend
harry redknapp will be discussing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the least surprising news of the
millennium is that kim kardashian seems
to ruin marilyn monroe's iconic dress
this is before on the left
on the right is what it now looks like
apparently all sorts of stuff went wrong
with it when kim kardashian tried to
burst herself into it that's why she
should have never been allowed anywhere
near the damn thing um there we are
uh kim kardashian ruins popular culture
who knew
uh sport washing what is it well it's
when a cold-shouldered controversial
country uses the prestige and popularity
of sport to whitewash its ugly
reputation the live golf series is the
latest sporting spectacle to face the
charge top stars have been offered
bottomless pits pots of saudi arabian
gold to join the breakaway league and
abandon the pga tour and to supporters
that's just business but to critics it
normalizes a saudi regime which uses
forced labor bombs children and yemen
and murders journalists so sport putting
money before morals well his golf
superstar rory mcilroy who spoke out
against the live golf invitational
series
i'm sure
not every saudi arabian is a bad person
and like it's
it's very you know we're talking about
this in such a generalized way and i've
spent a lot of time in the middle east
and the vast majority of people that
i've met there are very very nice people
but
there's
bad people everywhere and
you know the bad people that came from
that part of the world did some
absolutely horrendous things
now one of the most experienced premier
league managers of all time former
tottenham west ham boss harry redneck
harry great to talk to you
appears good talk to you
this sports washing um what do we make
of it i mean the principle behind it is
that these dodgy regimes corrupt regimes
that do terrible things have appalling
humans rights records
use sport by investing heavily into
sports to try and improve their image
what do you what do you feel about this
phenomenon we're seeing it more and more
known boxing and football and formula
one now in golf
i think it's been going on a long time
piers you know i mean we look we look
back to
you know people cleaned up their image
by buying football clubs coming to
england buying premier league clubs
it's something that's been going on
quite a while obviously with a saudi
situation and then the things that have
gone in their country
but you know they're coming they're now
owning a club in the premier league
newcastle and we can
you know we all feel strongly about the
things that have gone out going on in
that country but you know you can't tell
them geordie is 55 000 of them that turn
up every week to newcastle
they
you know they're not suddenly going to
stop going and the players have been
offered
enormous amounts of money to go on
playing this new golf
this new golf competition and golf tour
and they're going to take it i mean to
be honest they're not you know if
someone's coming off of them 50 60 100
million to to go and play golf and where
they can treble their earnings
they're gonna think well if i don't do
it somebody else would do it so
unfortunately that is the way to well
someone will come along and tomorrow and
say you know do you want to come out and
work in saudi we'll give you 10 times
what you're earning now it's very
difficult to turn it down i mean i think
my issue with it is there's a lot of
hypocrisy around this i mean take the
pga
who runs the biggest golf tournament in
the world of the series everybody wants
to be on it but the pga did let phil
mickelson a number of the other players
on this live tour now they did let them
play in a saudi tournament last year the
deal was they then had to play in the
pebble beach pro-am once in the next two
years that says to me this is not about
morality
it's about money
yeah but it's all about money and it
really
everything is about money really appears
you know we've had the boxing going to
saudi we've had you know
as i say they're now coming the only
clubs in the premier league and
you know nobody really you know the
newcastle players will go over to saudi
for a visit with the management team and
you know
um as i say in the jewellery the them
great newcastle fans who love their club
every week they're not the slightest bit
bothered who's money as long as he's
buying they're buying better players
they're winning more games they're up
the league
i've always said years ago if saddam was
saying that out of team they'd all be
singing there's only one saddam the fans
you know that is how it isn't it they're
only intrigued they
give us a winning team we don't care
what used to where your money come from
how many times have you seen it in this
country with people only buying sports
franchises who you know we all wonder
where their money's come from and
suddenly they changed their image they
cleaned their image up by i mean we
and he bought chelsea he gave him a
better image with the war in ukraine he
was unable to then denounce the war or
criticize putin because he would have
probably been killed by putin so he said
nothing and as a result he's lost it all
yeah i mean we don't actually know owns
off these premier league clubs anyway
really do we who you know we had people
you know i i hear stories this guy who
owned one club he now owns another club
in england but he's not the chairman
because his money it's owned by
the front man is somebody else they're
all you know they're using their money
to wash their money and um it's
so really it's we're not sure who's
actually behind after clubs in the
premier league i wouldn't think that
certainly a few of them anyway we've got
the world cup russian money and right
and i i clearly agree with you we've got
the world cup coming in qatar and as a
result it's not this summer as it should
be it's going to be in in our winter
and my issue with that is i saw fifa for
example you know fifa's been all over
pride month and talking about it we
should be celebrating
lgbt equality and gay rights and so on
and yet they've sold their most
prestigious
tournament the world cup to qatar where
it's illegal to be gay yeah yeah there's
a lot of hypocrisy again there isn't
that
absolutely well you know
listen we're not silly you're not you're
a clever man you know what what why is
it ended up there
you'd have to you know why we have all
the have had all these problems with set
blata platini and all these people
it's all is it corruption harry playing
yeah of course yeah it's got to be in it
why are they why they get why do they
get these tournaments you know you see
the russians you know you see putin with
johnny fence what's his name infantini
or where his name is
uh you know he's got getting him a
lovely nice uh
i don't know whether it was a gold watch
or what he was getting off him one day
but you know listen that's uh that's
that's that's how it works unfortunately
so we'll end up with with tournaments
you know
in places like that because it because
it suits the people to make the
decisions yeah
harry great to talk to you really
appreciate them it's a complex issue but
i think in the end you're right and i
think there's so much hypocrisy about
all this money will talk and the
hypocrites should yeah
hypocrites should take a back seat great
to talk to you
harry and you pierce well done mate bye
all the best
well finally tonight uh i've got a
ten-year-old little girl who i'm proud
to call my daughter but thankfully she
doesn't attend the burgess hill girls
school a couple of miles from where i
grew up well the world daughter is now
apparently offensive
[Applause]
yeah teacher of this school is a private
girls school in leafy west sussex won't
call her people's girls because she says
there are so many gender options
available this label says i use the word
students i said girls when you're
writing to parents it's difficult not to
use the word daughters sometimes child
or children suggest someone too young
you can't use the word daughters all the
time
about someone's little girl let me help
you headmistress can i call you
headmistress
little girls are somebody's daughters
stop the madness
that's it for tonight whatever you're
doing tonight keep it uncensored good
night
[Music]
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years at fleet street
there's loads of stories i could tell
you but actually i think i did an
overnight show for tall radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking um that remained at one and
at half past two quarter three after
nigel farage had already said he lost it
turned out he hadn't lost and it turned
out we were leaving the european union
so that was quite shocking
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm holly hudson it's now
unclear whether the first flight taking
asylum seekers from the uk to rwanda
will now take off after a last-minute
intervention by the european court of
human rights blocking the deportation of
one individual seven passengers were due
on board the plane which is on the
runway and expected to fly tonight it
comes after uk courts rejected legal
challenges by five of the men over their
removal
boris johnson has rejected nicola
sturgeon's new case for scottish
independence insisting the 2014 result
should be respected scotland's first
minister launched a refreshed campaign
for a second referendum earlier claiming
her government has an indisputable
mandate and the duke and duchess of
cambridge have joined grenfell tower
survivors at a special service to mark
five years since the tragedy a number of
events have taken place across the uk
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you